imagine that all the earth's oceans
disappeared for a day and imagine that
you being the excellent explorer you are
decided to go investigate
you travel across the continental shelf
down the continental slope and across
the abyssal plain you'd see gaping
trenches miles deep in the ground and
mountains taller than any mountain on
the continents and you might wonder what
causes such dramatic landscapes to be
formed
earth's lithosphere which is made up of
the crust and the upper part of the
mantle is broken up into large
puzzle-piece-like chunks called tectonic
plates these tectonic plates move around
slowly over millions of years on the
section of the mantle below the
lithosphere which we call the
asthenosphere
there are two types of tectonic plates
oceanic plates and continental plates
the continental plates as you've
probably guessed are the ones that make
up the continents the oceanic plates are
the ones that make up the sea floor the
main difference between oceanic plates
and continental plates is the type of
crust found on each plate
oceanic crust and continental crust are
made out of different kinds of rock the
continental crust contains a lot of
granite which is an igneous rock this
means that it was made out of rock that
was once molten the oceanic crust has a
lot of basalts in it which is another
kind of igneous rock the difference in
the kinds of rock that the crusts are
made out of means that the oceanic crust
is denser than the continental crust if
you took a cubic centimeter of the rock
from the continental crust it would be
about 2.7 grams a cubic centimeter from
the oceanic crust on the other hand
would weigh about 3 grams
while this difference in density might
not seem like much it completely changes
how tectonic plates interact
the high density of oceanic crust causes
oceanic plates to sinkage the
asthenosphere a bit more than
continental plates do
when an oceanic plate collides with
another plate at a convergent boundary
it always follows this rule the denser
plates always dives beneath the less
dense plate
when it's an oceanic plate and a
continental plate converging the denser
oceanic plates is the one that dips down
and when it's two oceanic plates that
are colliding the older denser oceanic
plate will move under the newer and less
dense oceanic plates
and over time the denser plate will be
recycled into the asthenosphere the
place where the plates collide is called
a subduction zone this bending of the
denser plates under the other creates a
trench
the deepest one is the marianas trench
which is located where the pacific plate
dives under the mariana plates the
trench is almost seven miles deep
the plate that sinks into the
asthenosphere often has some water and
fluids trapped inside of it these fluids
heat up and bubble to the surface the
hot fluids can cause sections of mantle
rock to melt into magma which then rises
to the surface and creates volcanoes
and you might be wondering if the
seafloor is constantly being destroyed
then what keeps the earth from shrinking
well new seafloor is constantly being
created too
this happens when two tectonic plates
move away from each other at a divergent
boundary when two plates diverge in the
middle of an ocean it creates a kind of
underwater mountain range called a
mid-ocean ridge
as the plates move apart at mid-ocean
ridges
magma moves up
cools and forms a new younger
lithosphere you can think of this
process like a really slow conveyor belt
new ocean seafloor is made of the ridges
and moves away from them over millions
of years
this means that the oceanic crust that
is closest to the ridge is the youngest
and as it moves away from the ridge the
crust gets older and older as it ages
the crust becomes cooler and more dense
and eventually it dips back down into
the asthenosphere at the trenches
the seafloor is perhaps the most
unexplored part of our planet so if they
do drain the ocean and you go for a walk
at the bottom of the sea i hope you'll
tell us all what it's like down there